nous sommes à quelques kilomètres
seulement de la frontière américaine
dans ce quartier très pauvre de tijuana
il y à ce havre de paix qui tranche avec
les environs
[Applaudissements]
dans cette petite école une centaine
d'élèves de 3 à 12 ans apprennent de
nouvelles choses pour avoir une sorte de
vie normale tous ces enfants sont des
migrants d'amérique centrale ils ont
tous à peu près la même histoire à
raconter celle d'avoir quitté un pays où
la pauvreté la peur et la violence
n'était plus supportable
comme daniel à 11 ans qui a quitté le
honduras avec sa mère elle est arrivée
ici il ya huit mois
grâce
auquel étaient invités à la super star
ne semble s
noval
pour lenny white heart qui a mis sur
pied cette école appelée nest le nid
c'est le seul endroit où les enfants
peuvent enfin se sentir en sécurité
depuis l'ouverture de l'école le nombre
d'élèves à 4 rue pelée il est passé de
25 à 100 8 par jour et l'école pensons
accueillir prochainement 300
parmi ces enfants qui en ont déjà tant
vu il y à justin 10 ans qui a fui la
violence quotidienne du salvador avec
son père et sa mère cela fait neuf mois
qu'il attend ici que leur dossier
d'immigration soit finalement traité est
acceptée par les états unis
[Musique]
primo ce qu'est guillaume a
estimé paul thériault mais avec la
frontière terrestre américaine fermée
depuis deux ans aux migrants et des
services d'immigration qui tourne au
ralenti
impossible de savoir quand son sort sera
connu alors en attendant il passe son
temps dans ce refuge situé juste à côté
de la petite école
il n'est pas le seul à y vivre entre 500
et 700 personnes cohabitent tant bien
que mal entassés dans une promiscuité
extrême
justin nous emmène dans ce qu'il appelle
sa chambre et amicalement dignité à ces
commence
pas pu dormir à 3 dans le même lit dans
une chaleur étouffante la journée et des
températures froid de la nuit c'est le
lot de beaucoup de familles ici derrière
chaque lit se cachent les destins peu
enviable de migrants qui ont tout perdu
et qui espère toujours
vanessa squibb elle une mexicaine de
tijuana qui donne un coup de main à tous
ces enfants de réfugiés et de demandeurs
d'asile nous fait visiter l'endroit
[Musique]
sans trop de moyens le refuge leur offre
les services minimum pour garder un
semblant de dignité
ici ils font la file pour recharger
leurs téléphones afin de garder le
contact avec tous ceux qui l'ont quitté
là on prépare la nourriture sur un
simple poêle à bois
quant à la lessive ici on attend chacun
son tour pour laver ses vêtements à la
façon d'une époque qui semble révolu le
quotidien des migrants se résume à
attendre attendre et attendre encore que
les etats-unis se penche sur leur
dossier
walter campos et de ceux qui essayent de
s'adapter à ces conditions difficiles
le fait d'aller à l'école à côté du
refuge lui permet de se distraire de
penser à autre chose et de relaxer car
walter enseigne les mathématiques aux
enfants qu'il côtoie tous les jours au
refuge salle est en place
on se trouve et où la menace il a quitté
le honduras parce qu'il était menacé
dans son école par un homme armé qui a
tiré
plusieurs mois après son arrivée à
tijuana on lui a dit que son dossier de
demande d'immigration allaient être
examinées mais c'est à ce moment que les
états unis ont fermé leur frontière
terrestre migrants
légaux ne reste presque
une famille qui peut enfin quitter le
refuge et l'école c'est une victoire en
demi-teinte ici non
[Musique]
walter qui enseigne et toute sa vie ne
sais pas ce qui va lui arriver et ça le
dévastent bien passé d'un putsch
je suis vraiment passionnée par ce
travail d'enseignant j'y ai mis tout mon
coeur c'est dur mais c'est la vie
justin espère devenir plus tard avocat
pour aider d'autres migrants
et il veut essayer de faire venir son
frère quand il aura traversé vers les
états unis
face à l'inconnu tous ici fonde beaucoup
d'espoir quant à l'engagement de la
maison blanche à rouvrir enfin la
frontière terrestre aux migrants d'ici
la fin du mois mais rien ne garantira
qu'ils seront acceptés dans ce pays tant
désiré